hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the very strong international
tournament that is the 1936
international tournament in Moscow here
we have a game between Mikhail Botvinnik
and Andre Lilian or under Lilienthal
whichever you prefer and I hope for
lilienthal needs no introduction as I've
already done a couple of videos about
him and did say a couple of words about
him as an introduction so if you haven't
seen those who do check out I will put
both of the links in the description
below
one is a game under Lilienthal that he
played against kappa blanka a year
before this this tournament it was 19 it
was between 1934 and 1935 in Hastings
and the Bobby Fischer had the highest
praises for that game
once the I didn't mention that story
when Bobby Fischer met under lilienthal
he just mentioned that one move that
lilienthal played against Capablanca
just you know saying that that was a
great move and you know you were a great
man and another one is my video i titled
the clash of legends that is Lilienthal
vs measurement Dino so I will put links
to both of these games in the
description below feel free to check
them out so now we have both universes
under Lilienthal it's a game from round
three of the international tournament in
Moscow 1936 the first two games like a
couple Blanc about tunic also drew here
and in the first two rounds both we had
the black pieces first game he drew
against Alaska and second game believe
it or not but tunic drew against Nikolay
Nikolayevich human the guy that
blundered the Queen to Capablanca in my
previous video so yeah that does happen
in chess so this is around number three
both unique faces under lilienthal
so let's check it out and I did find
some information about this game
actually winning the the brilliancy
prize in 1936 a Moscow tournament but I
couldn't verify it so I will still if I
will be able to verify it I will let you
know
Knight to f3 we have Knight to f6 c4 b6
g 3 and Bishop to b7 butter up to g2 we
have C 5 and so the English opening the
symmetrical variation we have castles by
Botvinnik g6 now going for the double
theme Cato
d4 and C
capture Sun before and I capture Sun d4
and the bishop captures energy too keen
captures saw the light square bishop
star of the board and Bishop to g7 now
Knight to c3
we have castles and E for now so but
when it pretty much replace very natural
moves just developing pieces controlling
controlling the center of C for D for
both of them controlling d5 and after
knight c6 and Bishop to e3 it's not all
that simple to find a nice game plan so
far okay blacks moves were also very
natural but now you kind of do want to
play do something with the deep one and
the e pawn you can to go d6 as your
knight would be hanging you can't really
push east six or if I for that matter if
you try something like this then Knight
b5 comes and then the knight is coming
to d6 it would be a very passive
position for black to play so after
Bishop to e3 we have Queen to see it
lilienthal gets the idea if he wants to
place his queen on b7 we have b3 Queen
to b7 and now F three protecting d4 pawn
and also not allowing any tactics with
this Queen v7 King g2 ideas rook F to d8
we have worked the c1 and not rook a to
c8 both of the rocks are now developed
Queen to d2 by botanic preparing maybe
if black closets on Bishop to h6 ideas
we have a six and now comes Luke F to D
one countering or both black rook Sun on
the sea and e-file Knight captures on d4
but should capture some d 4 and D 6 now
we have a 4 by botanic simply
controlling the board not allowing the
Lilienthal ending you know too much to
do we have 98 and now Knight to d5 a
very nice square for the knight
we have roped the c6 and now Bishop
captures and g7 Knight captures on g7
and now comes H for further controlling
the board we are rook to e8 as this
Knight is eyeing that epon and if the
Queen ever moves then this would be this
would be quite bad for black we have
route to c3 and now comes nice to h5 and
here we have Queen to d4
what could have seized the opportunity
with the g4 saying this night is it's
quite a lousy move but he prepares it
with Queen 2d for further pressuring the
b6 pawn now attacked twice but also
preparing g4 as the knight will no
longer be able to retreat to f6 and well
the black is pretty much running out of
options here
so the although this was the best move
for Black Knight to f6 was not played
here lilienthal played b5 breaking the
tension on the Queen side but nice 12:6
was in fact the best move because now
after Knight captures pawn captures both
winning doesn't have the option of
actually capturing on f6 because after
Queen captures d5 is coming opening up
an attack towards the bottom takes Queen
and after Queen moves then comes the D
captures on e4 e F captures on e4 and
now rooks e36 with this triple attack on
d4 pawn and slightly lose White King
black would definitely have nice a nice
position and compensation here
so after this Queen to d4 move
Lilienthal didn't find Knight to f6
rather he went for b5 we have seek after
some b5 a capture some b5 rook d 2 c1
doubling up rook captures on c3 captures
on c3 and b captures on a4 and here you
do have a couple of options you could
recapture the pawn a capture a beak a
present a 4 you could play Queen
captures on a4 but if you are a beginner
then you should really train yourself a
train your brain not to do automatic
captures you know if he captures my pawn
I'm just gonna capture his bony feet
captures my piece I'm just gonna capture
his piece chess is about something more
so here I want you to pause the video
and try to find the in-between move
Botnick played that immediately wins the
game for white so I will give it a
couple of seconds for you to the side so
you know feel free feel free to to try
and solve this very nice idea so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you've just spotted an
excellent move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show here
botanics played rook to c7
the idea is very simple you do have to
move the Queen your queen is under
attack and then Knight captures on e7 is
coming whatever black plays here the
obvious Queen captures on B 3 losses
instant
because after night captors on e7 check
King moves and queen to h8 is checkmate
and even if you don't play King to f8 if
you capture the night then hope to see
it will again be checkmate as the King
has nowhere to go ro casts the block and
then rook captures on e8 will once again
be checkmate
so after this rook to c7 lilienthal
thought he only had one idea
he played Queen to b5 and now both tunic
believe it or not played be captured on
a4 it's very interesting that Knight
captures on e7 also wins on the spot of
course nice Oh King to f8 runs into
checkmate and of course after rook
captures you cannot play rook to CH
check because Rock would simply block
the queen is now protecting the AE 8
from b5 but you can simply capture this
and after a capture some b3 yes that is
a very annoying passed pawn but simply
rook to c7 with the threat of rope to
see it will win the game on the spot you
have to prevent this let's say queenie 5
for single trade queen chapter strong
characters and after ruby 7 you will win
the pawn and then you have a winning end
game but Botvinnik says you know I'm not
that kind of a guy I want to play be cat
person a4 and now if you capture my pawn
I'm gonna do this just the same but I've
at the end of this variation you're not
gonna have a past beep on so very nice
move by botanique but he also has to
figure out what happens after Queen to
e2 check so Queen captures immediately
loses to this move so he tried Queen to
e2 check we have Queen to f2 and now
Queen captures King captures and now
comes a six protecting his pawn
we have nice to b6 Knight to f6 now a5
now that is a that is a powerful passed
pawn so what when you will push it as
best points must be pushed ruby 8 now
preventing a 6 as the knight would fall
but simply rope to see it with check
forcing a trade of knights rook captures
the knight captures and now Knight comes
to e8 we have a six-night to c7
attacking the past born we have pawn to
a 7 and now point a knife to e8 and
although the material on the board is
equal for the moment Knight captures and
e6 is coming and it will be very hard
for
the plateless it's a completely winning
position for white and it's very
educational how about tuning does he
plays Knight captures on d6 we have King
to f8 lilienthal tries to activate his
King we have E 5 protecting the night
King e7 now King III what eunuch also
tries to activate his wing not trice he
attempts at activation of asking now we
have f6 and now 98 check who followed ye
captures on f6 is winning winning also
but botnik plays another winning idea
simply came to a4 and now you don't want
to capture on e5 that would simply
improve sorry that would simply improve
the position of White King and also
white doesn't really want to capture on
f6 immediately that would simply improve
the position of the black king but as
black doesn't really have all that much
to do he pushes h6
we have Knight to c8 check King moves
and now King e5 King to g7 King d4
Knight to c7 black can only wait and see
what happens
King c5 and it was in this position
unmoved 44 that under lilienthal
resigned to the game well if you resign
well there's really no defense whatever
black plays white will simply go after
the knight Knight moves Kimi attacks
night and it's all over
after the knight moves king will capture
it and then promote his a point to a
queen so as you can see there were a lot
of different ways in which botany could
have won this game but both eunuch you
know it shows the the simplest one which
is always the correct thing to do so
yeah and he didn't go especially in this
position that was very funny here after
Queen b5 he didn't go for Knight
captures on e7 if you calculated this
position you can easily reach you know a
deposition and understand that it's
completely winning for white but
Botvinnik says nope I'm gonna capture
the a four point first and then I'm
gonna play this it's mean it's the same
idea but why leave black with an extra
point to worry about even for one more
move that's the kind of guy but when it
was even at such a young age so yeah
that's the game and it's very
interesting how after drawing two games
he wins this one against such a strong
opponent and a cup of Blanc after
drawing
you know basically gets a free win
against a player who drew against
botanique in the second round so a very
interesting tournament so far the 1936
international tournament in Moscow I do
hope you're enjoying it and we're gonna
check out a couple of more of them so
yeah once again if you haven't voted for
my next big series there will be a link
in the description below also you can
check two of my previous videos here and
do check two of the videos played
between energy Medina and Kappa bla
sorry between Lilienthal and kappa
blanka and between Lilienthal and nojima
deunov as if this is the first time
you're hearing about under Lilienthal
definitely do check them out so yeah
once again I do hope you enjoy them
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon